hey guys today we're gonna be looking at
what season 1 would have been like if
deku had never met all mine now this
video was inspired by a recent video
that I did which kind of reviewed the
five luckiest moments in my hair Kadima
so far as you can imagine the number one
spot went to Deku being saved by his
idol and then getting offered his quark
later that same day life comes at you
fast people for this video though I'll
be referring to the real series as
timeline 1 and this new reality in which
they never meet as timeline 2 also the
calendar year in which the sludge
villain first appeared that's gonna be
year 1 and then the following year where
the entrance exam actually takes place
that's gonna be referred to as year 2
but with that explained
let's get into it and don't forget to
sub in timeline to the season would
begin with Deku as the protagonist I
know the in reality it's highly likely
that it would have started with me Ryo
as the main character and just
completely ignored aku's backstory and
Charlton but I feel for this video it
makes things a bit clearer if we at
least start with Deku as the main guy
with that being the case every event
that we saw in timeline 1 before he met
all my would proceed as normal so this
means that he's still quite clear he
still attends the same middle school and
back ago still tells him to kill himself
pretty rude if I do say so myself
the main point where the story would
begin to diverge is the moment in
timeline one where Deku is attacked by
the sludge form so we see the villain
come out of the sewer here and then all
might emerges from it some moments later
and as we should all know by this point
the symbol of peace doesn't just chill
in the sewer guys like he had been
following this creature after it had
robbed a store earlier that day now
given it was only a matter of seconds
until all Mike came to save Deku it's
clear that when chasing this villain all
might wasn't actually far behind at all
therefore in timeline 2 if the zoo crew
had arrived at the underpass around 5 or
10 minutes later for example the
situation likely would have already been
resolved as all might would have taken
this thing down and then hopped over to
the police station and I do mean like
literally hopped over the bottle
containing the sludge villain wouldn't
have dropped to like it did in timeline
1 and even if it had all might could
have realized and picked it up as Deku
wouldn't have been there harassing him
and distracting him so dec who goes home
that day from school without meeting all
my and he has no clue what could have
been had he just arrived at the
underpass a few minutes earlier we know
from timeline 1 that Dec who was still
fully intending to apply to you a even
without a quirk with
three reasons why he wouldn't have been
successful in time line two as well
might says getting into you a without a
quirk just isn't possible it's a simple
reality that people have to accept now
there's nothing to suggest that deku
would have somehow manifested a quirk
before the exam given that to this day
in time line one
he still yet to show us any kind of
power that isn't derived from one for
all so if he takes the exam he's still
gonna be Quercus secondly because he
never met all my he wouldn't have been
able to train on the personalized
workout program that all my gave him
even with this intense regime deck who
still nearly failed the test if not for
a last-second display of heroism so
without a quirk and without a training
program his chances of passing would
have been even worse the acceptance rate
aua is really really tough like only one
student gets in for every 300 applicants
so it's just not happening final thing
we know that back ago had been bullying
and intimidating deku to prevent him
from applying to UA and of course he
would have continued to do this possibly
leading to Deku dropping out before the
exam this is more likely to happen in
timeline too because unlike timeline 1
deku doesn't have the promise of gaining
a crack before he does the exam so he'd
be more susceptible to back agos
intimidation this leaves us with two
possibilities for the entrance exam
either deck who gives up before the big
day and pursues a more realistic career
path which is something he was going to
do in time and one just before all my
offered him one for all or the second
possibility is that he still goes
through with the exam and just fails
either way the end result is that Deku
doesn't get into UA and for the time
being he gives up on his hero dream much
the packet goes pleasure so moving on
from Deku for the rest of the series we
need to follow someone else and
obviously at UA there are a ton of
potential heroes who could act as main
characters but the reason we followed
Deku as the protagonist in town line one
is because he is the successor to all
mine and is eventually the one who's
gonna come to blows with alpha 1 or
sugar aki with that being the case our
focus will now flashback to all might at
the beginning of year 1 as he searches
for a new successor we know that months
prior to the sludge villain appearing
all might had been looking for the next
potential one for all user and was
contacted by UA when this happened
principal mezu made him an offer to
become a teacher at the school and
presented him with the perfect candidate
who was Class B student Mariota gotta
all might even omit in town line one
had he not run into Deku before he could
meet me Rio the Miriah would have been
the next holder of one for all therefore
the question now becomes when in
timeline two would all my offer me Rio
the quark and I think I've worked out
when in timeline 1 deku in all might
meet each other around April of year 1
and spend the next 10 months training
for the UA entrance exam during the same
period of time night I found out that
one for all is going to midoriya and
after failing to convince all might to
change his mind tonight I decided to
take on me Rio as an apprentice and
teach him the ways of the force or
something like that it was because of
night eyes training specifically the
Maria went from an average student to
the best student at UA during that 10
month period no one in the public knew
that all might was going to be a teacher
at UA so what does that mean exactly
well for starters I think it makes the
most sense that in timeline - all might
does not offer me Rio one for all until
after this public announcement that he's
going to be joining you a as a teacher
all might has a habit of withholding
information until it becomes relevant
for example it wasn't until the sports
festival that he told deku that he was
also Quercus as a kid and it wasn't
until season four that he mentioned
night eyes prophecy about how he might
die there are other examples but the
point is who might rarely gives away the
game upfront what I think is most likely
is that he has an arranged meeting with
me Rio at some point during year 1 just
to see if they share similar values and
if they're compatible now assuming this
meeting takes place and everything goes
well night I would find out about all my
intention to pass the colectomy Rio in
much the same way that he found out
about midoriya only this time the
conversation between all my tonight sigh
goes a lot differently rather than
criticizing the choice as he did for
midoriya night I would be a lot more
receptive to this idea especially once
finding out you know the humor and
energy that me Rio would bring as the
next symbol of peace however I don't
think it's crazy to suggest that not I
would at least be partially concerned by
Mario's average grades and would offer
to take him on a work study to mold him
into the perfect model symbol of peace
this would be a logical scenario as
Knight I could build up me Rio to be the
perfect vessel for one for all during
year one and then when all might joins
you away as a teacher in year two and
you know passes the crack on me Rio
would be more than ready to receive it
there's no way Almighty would turn down
an offer like this and it would actually
help to rekindle the relationship
between you know him and his former
sidekick with all that said I
think it's time for us to map out how
the rest of the season would go if this
was all the case so in time one we spend
one Episode on deck who's first day at
school then a few more episodes on the
practical training before the last five
episodes of the season cover the usj
attack in a similar pattern it would
make sense to spend one episode on
mirrors first day of his work study with
sanity this is where he'd begin the
journey of learning how to predict his
opponents attacks and becoming the model
student over the next three to four
episodes we could get into some really
dangerous or interesting missions that
Miriah went on with sanity that we never
got to see in the main series he'd be
fighting or investigating you know as
part of the night I agency and it would
show us the process of how he truly
mastered his permeation quark these work
study episodes could span over the
course of a few months in timeline too
in which people at you way then begin to
notice muirios rapid improvement this
arrangement would still continue all the
way into year 2 when all might would be
publicly announced as a teacher at UA
after this announcement it would make
sense that night I would request a
meeting with miryo at his agency before
the new school year begins only this
time when Mireille arrives all might
would also be there to greet him all
might would then deliver the absolute
bombshell that is the secret of one for
all and how he wants Miriah to succeed
him
one thing I would be curious to know is
Mira's reaction to needing to eat or
mites hair to receive one for all for
some reason I feel like he chew on it
really enthusiastically the next part of
Mario's journey would be spending his
third year mastering the invincible
combination that his permeation +1 for
all because Mario's finishing moves are
all close combat attacks is logical that
he'd work on activating one for all just
before the point of contact for an
additional powerup also he'd be able to
now use long-range attacks unlike in the
main series
so to recap everything so far almighty
easily takes out the sludge villain in
year one with no complications then
meets miryo for a chat and mentally
decides that he will pass one floor on
to me Rio Knightley then agrees to train
the next user of one for all on a work
study much like he did in timeline 1 and
at this point Mario knows nothing about
one fraud then just before the new
school year starts mario is now a model
student and is offered one for all by
all might at sanitize agency meanwhile
in the background Deku fails to get into
UA
however back ago and everyone else let
me know still get in though I do wonder
who would
been able to save our choco from this
giant robot here because Dec who doesn't
get on to the hero course naturally
someone else would have taken his place
and he could have been Shinzo as we know
he took the entrance exam as well or
maybe it's just his random guy here I
mean eNOS I applied as well but he
rejected you a so I don't think that
would have changed at all
based on deku getting in or not getting
in with that recap out of the way I
think it's relevant of me to point out
that we actually have no idea what
academic life is truly like for the
third-year students I mean beyond just
their work studies in timeline - I kind
of wonder if all might would help to
teach class 3 be in the end I do think
he would have to do this because
principal mezu would be aware of miryo
being the successor and would likely
pull some strings to facilitate a closer
relationship between myrio and all might
in order to train myrio to use one for
all I'd imagine all might would need
that closer relationship with class 3b
than we've ever seen in timeline one but
I don't know if that's instead of class
1a or an addition to cross 1a so for now
I'm just gonna say that all my teachers
class 1a but in addition because of
myrio he also helps out with class 3b so
regarding how season 1 would end
remember that the league of villains
attacked you way in time line 1 because
they knew that all Mike was teaching
there and they created this special usj
nomu with the sole intention of killing
the symbol of peace so that plant goes
ahead regardless of whether Decker has
one for all or muirios one for all
anyone else has one for all like they
don't care about that at this point they
didn't even know that all my had passed
on the quirk what this means is that the
villains actions wouldn't really change
at all because their actions weren't
dictated by where the deku had one for
all in the first place this means that
they would have attacked you way and
around the same time in timeline - as
they did in timeline 1 when looking back
at the whole usj incident shigaraki said
that if it wasn't for dec whose presence
they would have been able to kill all my
so this means whoever replaces Deku has
quite a big job to do with Shinzo their
things would have played out a lot
differently like my dude could have just
brainwashed shigaraki and then made
sugar aki decay denouement for all we
know he could have done that but um what
I do suspect is that all Mike would
still have come out victorious against
the no move regardless of whether Shinzo
or dec who was there and I have a couple
of reasons why I think this I mean just
for the sake of the plot it would have
been way too early for you know all my
to die I mean he would have barely had a
chance to train me Ryo at this point so
I think this
would finish with all my Ennis hospital
bed Emilio is kind of like sitting next
to him and it's just like what the hell
happened they would have a conversation
in which all my realizes that it's time
to reveal night eyes prediction about
his death I mentioned it earlier but all
might discloses information when the
time is right so in this context with me
Rio being night eyes apprentice yes I
think it's only logical that all might
would mention it to me Rio at this
moment and that could serve as like the
cliffhanger for season one the fact that
Maria finds out all my is gonna die
pretty soon and so we kind of like need
to get the ball rolling on in terms of
training as a side note it's possible
that when Miriah receives the quirk he
might be able to use it at a hundred
percent full cowling right from the
start in much the same way that all
might was able to do that when he first
received it now naturally the power of
one floor is a lot stronger now than it
was back then but Miriah would have been
molded by niya tights for this exact
purpose so I do think it is possible if
not a hundred percent then maybe fifty
percent but what do you guys think is me
Rio as much of a natural-born hero as
all might was to be able to do this
anyway that's all I think season one
would have gone had Deku never met all
my whatever you think be sure to leave
it down below it's all hypothetical so I
mean there's I'm sure there's many
variables that I didn't account for but
hey it's just a bit of fun so be sure to
subscribe if you haven't already as we
are on the road to 70,000 and peace out